Boah, hast du gerade gefurzt?
Ja, wieso?
- Alter.
Also, ich rieche nix.
- Was?
Untertitel: ARD Text im Auftrag
von Funk (2017)
Melanie M. möchte wissen,
warum wir unsere eigenen Fürze
gar nicht so schlimm finden.
Eine wunderbare Frage
und ein super Smalltalk-Thema
für die nächste WG-Party.
Zunächst mal:
Warum furzen wir überhaupt?
Ein Mensch furzt 10-20 Mal pro Tag.
Das sind weltweit
so 75-150 Mrd. Fürze pro Tag.
Die Gase, aus denen ein Furz besteht,
kommen hauptsächlich
aus zwei Quellen.
1.: überschüssige Luft, die wir
durchs Essen zu uns nehmen.
Und 2.: die Luft oder die Gase,
die entstehen, wenn unser Essen
im Darm fermentiert wird.
Für den Gestank sind schwefelhaltige
Moleküle verantwortlich,
die von unserer Dickdarm-Flora
beim Verarbeiten des Essens
produziert werden.
Z.B.das Molekül H2S,
Schwefelwasserstoff,
das nach verfaulten Eiern riecht.
Mhm.
Weitere Stinki-Moleküle findet ihr
in dieser wundervollen Infografik
von Compound Interest,
wo Körpergerüche
chemisch runtergebrochen werden,
Link in der Beschreibung.
Ansonsten bestehen Fürze
aus geruchslosen Gasen,
hauptsächlich Wasserstoff,
Stickstoff und CO2.
Deshalb gilt auch die Faustregel:
je lauter ein Furz...
* Furzgeräusch *
Desto weniger stinkt er.
Da eine hohe Pupslautstärke mit
einem größeren Gasvolumen einhergeht,
was meist bedeutet, dass die Stinki-
Moleküle stärker verdünnt sind.
Bevor wir weitermachen,
möchte ich kurz eure Aufmerksamkeit
auf die Wissenschaftler lenken,
dank denen wir das überhaupt wissen.
Denkt ihr,
so eine Furz-Zusammensetzung
lässt sich theoretisch herleiten?
Nein. Das wurde alles
experimentell bestimmt.
In dieser Studie z.B. wurden
Furzproben von Probanden gesammelt,
die zuvor Bohnen gegessen hatten.
Yep.
Dann wurden die Inhaltsstoffe
dieser Furz-Proben
anhand von Gas-Chromatographie
bestimmt.
Und zuletzt wurden diese Furzproben
Wertungsrichtern vorgelegt,
welche diese anhand einer Skala
von 0, geruchslos, bis 8, offensive,
bewerten sollten.
True story.
Alles für die Wissenschaft.
Jedenfalls warum empfinden wir diese
Gerüche überhaupt als unangenehm?
Unschöne Gerüche sind oft
ein gesundheitliches Warnzeichen.
Jegliche Körperausscheidungen
sind potentielle Herde
für Krankheitsüberträger,
die gemieden werden sollten.
Fragt man allerdings Eltern,
so empfinden die
die Windeln ihrer Babys deutlich
angenehmer als die von fremden Babys.
Auch hier hilft uns
unsere Wahrnehmung dabei,
uns gut um unseren Nachwuchs
zu kümmern.
Was ist jetzt
mit unseren eigenen Fürzen?
Na ja, der Geruch
unserer eigenen Fürze
wird maßgeblich von
unserer eigenen Darmflora bestimmt,
die uns nicht nur wohl bekannt,
sondern auch einzigartig ist.
Fürze sind ein bisschen
wie stinkende Fingerabdrücke.
Da jeder Mensch sein
einzigartiges Set an Bakterien hat.
* Klaviermusik *
Und bei Fürzen gilt dasselbe wie
in vielen anderen Teilen des Lebens.
Nämlich: Was wir kennen,
das mögen wir.
Hinzu kommt ein psychologischer
Effekt, denn wenn ich furze,
bin ich ja auf
den folgenden Gestank vorbereitet.
Aber wenn ich von einem fremden Furz
überrascht werde,
empfinde ich diesen schon allein
wegen der Überraschung
als deutlich unangenehmer.
Schönschlau.
Vielen Dank noch mal an Melanie M.
für deine Frage.
Wie geht es euch?
Findet ihr eure Fürze auch nicht so
schlimm? Oder vielleicht doch?
Oder gehört ihr zu
den geruchsunempfindlichen Menschen?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bis dahin. Bleibt sicher.